un año con cifras récord de migración en
Estados Unidos El último dato anual de
encuentros registrados por agentes
federales es de 2,5 millones en este
contexto se celebra la Cumbre de Los
tres amigos lunes y martes el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden y su homólogo
canadiense Justin trude se reunirán con
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador la migración será uno de
los temas principales antes del
encuentro biden visita el domingo El
Paso Texas con el objetivo de hacer
presencia en una frontera cuya situación
quiere revertir con una nueva política
migratoria la semana pasada anunció que
los cubanos nicaragüenses haitianos y
venezolanos que ingresen de forma
irregular a Estados Unidos serán
expulsados a México y tendrán vetada la
entrada al país durante cinco años esto
bajo la polémica ley título 42 heredada
de la era Trump por el contrario
permitirán que 30.000 personas de estos
países puedan acceder cada mes con un
permiso humanitario si lo solicitan en
línea y encuentran un patrocinador
también se hablará de narcotráfico esta
semana México capturó Ovidio Guzmán hijo
del Chapo y miembro del Cartel De
Sinaloa una detención que ha sido vista
como un gesto a Estados Unidos cuya
política es la persecución de las
cabezas del narco para una vez detenidas
lograr su extradición López Obrador a
cambio pedirá más esfuerzos a biden para
frenar el tráfico de armas esto con
Canadá centrándose en el ámbito
económico con el objetivo de potenciar
El acuerdo de libre comercio y dirimir
las 17 disputas comerciales que
mantienen